[Music]
Julia Roberts
she plays Jacob Tremblay his mom and the
drama wonder and it was career milestone
for Julia it's currently still found out
though what that milestone was was even
a shock to Julia this is your 50th film
wonder it is yes which is what
incredible it's your 50th film what do
you remember about your first acting job
my first acting job was on a TV show
called crime story mom I don't like you
being out half the night that was my
first job and I had an incredibly
wonderful experience on it well now in
wonder Julia is helping her son with
facial differences deal with school for
the first time I'll see you later when
was the first time you realized that
your co-star was kind of a big deal
25 minutes when I heard that I was gonna
do a role with the one and only Julia
Roberts
I was so it I was always just like with
her as my mom I'm gonna put the money in
your pocket
good job we all have marks on her face
all I really have to do is listen to him
and look into his sweet eyeballs and and
connect with him which was very easy for
me eleven-year-old Jacob had to play
some tough scenes about looking
different I have been bullied in the
past because I'm pretty short for my age
I mean I know I know I know how it feels
and I know it hurts and in addition to
it being Julia's 50th film she also just
turned 50 I celebrated with my family
with Danny and the kids and we just had
a beautiful time in San Francisco and
ate a lot of good food and had a great
cake and yeah sweet
[Music]
you